all right hello we're back with yet
another analysis
and this time we have entered a knockout
stage
in the skilling open today and
the game we will take a look at is
magnus carlsen against
anish giri the very first game played in
their
in their match let's see
how this showdown went so magnus went
for d4
knight f6 from geary c4 e6
not f3 d5
and here knight c3 very
uh standard so far
and now geary went for bishop b4 this
line is known as the
ragosa and it's a very complicated line
and both of these players have played
this line several times in their in
their encounters
let me briefly mention that c6 hair is a
huge move
along with dtx4 and also bishop e7 which
is
known as the nakamura variation
but bishop b4 is the most dynamic
approach out of all of them
these positions can become pretty wild
magnus he takes on d5 takes back from
magiri
and here magnus plays bishop f4 i'm not
sure whether or not
this is the most common move i think
bishop g5 is slightly more common
also queen a4 here is played quite a
little bit to
to force the knight to go to c6 this is
good for white because black
wants to play c6 this is slightly
awkward
this line is known as a very solid line
and i can also mention that queen b3
here is a huge move
which is very very sharp but see it's
xd5 and then bishop f4
knight e4 geary doesn't wait he just
jumps into
e4 right off the bat immediately
and i think that is also the right
approach rook c1 magnus has to
has to defend c3 knight c6 from
from geary he just simply wants to
put the knight on an active square
playing c6 could probably be alright but
i think it's slightly slow when you've
started with knight e4 here
so then black needs to be be faster so
knight c6 is
uh is a good move e3 and
here geary launches with his g
pawn plays g5 this is a very standard
move and once you put your knight on e4
the point is that you chase away the
bishop and after bishop g3 h5
you are now threatening to capture and
trap the bishop of
h4 and this is not so easy to defend
the only way to do that is to lift up
the h pawn but when that that happens
black can take on g3 and give you these
double pawns and these are not
very desirable for white at all
and this also happened in the game and
here
geary played g takes h4 uh to me this
was slightly
surprising when i first saw this
i thought the g4 was more logical to
just
chase away than knight uh i'm actually
quite baffled by why i didn't do that
and
do this maybe he thought that after
knight g1 he doesn't really have
anything after knight e2 united 4.
the knight on f4 is conveniently placed
because it blocks this diagonal right
here
so it's not so simple for black to
attack the g3 pawn for example bishop d6
knight e2 i'd say 97 is logical here to
protect the d5 pawn
and after knight f4 knight f5 black and
white can simply play
king f2 and you're protecting both upon
uh e3 and g3
and maybe gary thought that here he
doesn't have anything
that's my only explanation
but to me g4 looked like a more logical
move
but maybe it was more clever to take on
h4
to to simply try to open up a little bit
more
and hear magnus he doesn't even take
back at least bishop b5 and i think this
is an excellent move
pinning tonight here and now knight e5
is definitely
in the air and also queen b3 and a few
lines
queen d6 from from geary this is a
certainly a
surprising move but he's attacking g3 so
in that sense it's fairly
fairly logical i would think that
simply taking the pawn can't be a bad
move and
something like queen b3 could happen
now what white is threatening to take
the bishop
uh the queen could maybe move to e7
attack e3 and protect the bishop
and here i would maybe castle with white
and we have a crazy position that's
that's everything i can say
for example bishop takes rook takes
bishop d7
this position is completely crazy where
anything can happen
a queen h4 is something you have to be
very careful of
but i think it's uh it's alright for
white at least
crazy mess that's all i can say but
queen d6
is also a logical try but it's not a
very good move
uh indeed the best move here would have
been
to simply castle but magnus did not do
that
so after castle the position is
crazy it's uh wide but the point is that
if you take with the queen i can simply
play
knight e2 here and then now you're
forced to play
queen d6 in order to protect your
protect your knight but then i have
knight e5
attacking c6 and i'm also attacking f7
so this is not gonna work out very well
for black
so maybe it's better to take with the h
pawn but knight e5 is yet again
an issue and i think that
white is doing well with queen b3 next
potentially also knight e2
taking the pawn of g3 so
uh castles would have been a very cold
but extremely
good move in this position very
difficult to see so then g takes h4
makes slightly more sense
queen g3 king f1 the attack is not
dangerous yet but white certainly has to
be careful
rook g8 rook g1 protecting
protecting g2 and as a matter of fact uh
the best move here
is to play queen e2 simply and protect
with
with the queen the issue after rook g1
is that black can take on c3 like kiri
does
rook takes c3 and then simply bishop d7
and he is going to castle very quickly
and he could double on the g
file and this could become very very
dangerous for for magnus here
as we will see later in in the game and
in this position we actually see why
it's so clever to put the queen on e2
so now uh the dream here for white would
have been to take on c6 bishop takes c6
and then play knight e5
so if the queen was on e2 we would have
prevented black from playing bishop b5
but now that the the queen is not on e2
bishop b5 here
simply wins for for black but if the the
queen would have been on e2
white would have had a winning position
so
that is the deep point behind queen e2
it's kind of
crazy but it's very fascinating
magnus goes for rxc5 a6 bishop a4
queen back to d6 i'm not such a fan of
that move i remember that my old coach
used to say that backward moves are
always
bad and i do think that is the case in
here as well because i think it could be
better to go for a long castle it's
slightly more direct and after rook
takes d5
maybe simply play bishop e6 and we get a
position like this
which is very dynamic
and this queen is bugging white quite a
lot i would be very
very uncomfortable here with bishop c4
in the air and
stuff like 97.95 could come quickly too
or knight of f5 as well
but gear went for queen d6 texas c6 is a
good move
takes 95 now that queen is no longer on
g3
magnus makes use of this so he decides
to take
there's no now we have king e1 castles
and
uh king d2 from magnus so he seems
he simply wants to uh to escape
he wants to escape but it's uh easier
said than uh
than done rook d8 rook e8 here is a good
move
from uh from geary and um he's
threatening to take on e5 and then on c5
so magnus he takes on h5 protecting the
knight with with the queen
f6 from geary knight f3 and
and it's very very dangerous for for
magnus right now
the rook is attacking the e3 pawn queen
g3
now queen f2 is a massive threat which
is very hard to deal with
magnus checks on f5 king b8 then he
plays
queen f4 so queen f2 is still possible
it happened in the game
king c1 it does look like magnus is out
of the woods
because he is threatening to take on c7
but as a matter of fact
that is far from the truth here but
kyrie takes on e3
a very poor move it's uh
it makes black lose pretty much all of
his advantage
and the winning move would have been to
play simply bishop e2
the point is simple we want to take take
on f3
and then take the rook the only way to
prevent this
is pretty much to play rook c2 queen
takes e7 leads to
to nothing so rook c2 pinning the bishop
but now root takes g2
comes with devastating effect and if we
take back that rook
queen f1 is uh going to lead to mate
just queen d1 queen d3 so that will be
mate
so white cannot take the rook and if you
cannot take the rook
then this knight will be hanging and the
position is resignable so that is
geary and in a nutshell i would say that
he's extremely well prepared and very
very strong in the opening
but he does seem to have some issues
converting he has blown so many winning
positions
he tends to do that in
longer games as well as far as i've seen
so that is the main place he he needs to
improve because his
his opening preparation is absolutely
incredible he's always extremely well
prepared
and he pretty much always gets a very
good position out of the opening too as
far as i've seen
the queen takes e3 this move was
inaccurate and after queen takes
rook takes rookie one takes the rook
knight takes the rook this end game here
is quite equal
rook takes d5 rook takes h4 we can see
now that we have four pawns
against uh four pawns
rook f5 rook takes d4 rook takes f6
rook g4 rook f2 defending the pawn
bishop c6 knight f3 bishop d5
a3 the bishop is slightly better than
the knight but it's not enough to win
the game
and the game is easily drawn for magnus
he decides to even
sacrifice the pawn on g2 because of the
fact that these two pawns
against these three pawns is a simple
draw takes takes
b4 a5 king c3
takes takes king b6 king d4
bishop h3 knight d3 king c6
king e5 bishop g4 knight c5
you can see that a white prevents
black from playing c5 and it's also
impossible for black to get his king
moving
so the game is an easy draw knight b6
king b6 knight c5 king c6 knight b3
king b6 knight c5 king c6
with a draw so a very good start
uh by giri i must admit he
impressed me there in the opening very
well played unfortunately for him he was
unable to convert
that happens i've done that a million
times myself
and we will see what this
knockout match is going to bring i'm
sure we will find
many many exciting games just like
this one